what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so as much as I love Marvel and DC even
I have to admit but after a while the
same superheroes all the time kind of
grow a little thin I love what's going
on in Marvel right now with a lot of the
characters all-new all-different Hydra
Captain America is really cool Superman
rebirth and actually comics is amazing
but sometimes you just have to break
away from the familiar and you have to
go with the unfamiliar now valiant has
been amazing to us at the weekly pool
and I would be remiss if I did not do
what I was supposed to have done and
make valiant videos for them Josh John
if you see this video I love you we are
going to talk about XO Man O'War uh
here's the cool thing about valuing
comics so values whole mantra is like
the world outside your window right I
mean it's like if people are going to
read comic books and they're going to
try to get into scale they're going to
try to move away from the real world and
they want to be able to kind of jump
into this realm of adventure then why
not do it in such a way that there's a
measure of familiarity because I don't
know about you guys when it comes to
like stories I find saris to be more
interesting and a bit more tangible if I
can kind of relate to what's going on to
a degree you know like if a story takes
place in New York City as opposed to
like Gotham City it makes a little more
realistic a little more grounded and
that's really kind of valiant thing
Diane goes for the whole superhero
concept but only insofar as it's a
legitimate possibility of something that
could actually happen and that's why it
works so well I mean you look at the
idea of Superman and it's like it is a
guy from outer space you know when you
come from a planet Krypton and it's like
it's cool which Superman can never
actually exist
you know Batman's about as close to a
real-life superhero in DC Comics as
somebody could get and even then you'd
have to have hundreds of millions of
dollars if not billions of dollars to be
Batman
however with Valiant Comics it's not
that way you've got like Harbinger you
know you've got these kids that show up
and suddenly they've got the ability to
read minds or the ability to control
other people's minds and that's not
entirely possible when it would be that
humanity could tap into that we don't
know but these are the kind of things
that value does they grab these concepts
and they make them tangible a really
good example of this is the way that X
amount of War opens up with the Battle
of palencia I think his house pronounced
in northern Italy and 402 ad now this
was a real world conflict between the
Roman Empire and the biggest
what had happened up to this point was
that the Vista Goths were basically part
of the Roman military and this was kind
of like when the Roman Empire I think
was on it severally on those last days
but one of the things that contributed
to the fall of the Roman Empire because
the way that it used to be was when the
Roman Empire conquered the territory you
became part of Roman society you worship
the Roman gods you
all the Roman customs you are part of
the Roman military if you were capable
of fighting and that's all there was to
it with regards to the Visigoths they
were like contractors so to speak you
know they were like you know soldiers of
fortune mercenaries for hire you know
they were brought in by the Roman Empire
to fight alongside them but the issue
was that they eventually defected under
the idea they basically just weren't
being paid enough they weren't being
compensated adequately and what they did
is to basically draw the ire of the
Roman Empire and to show how formidable
they were the Visigoths began this
conquest of like spreading across Europe
attacking these different places
Constantinople different things like
that and it resulted in King Alaric
basically creating kind of a foundation
for himself a solid power structure at
that point he instigated a conflict with
Rome in northern Italy and that's where
this story picks up now force which is
being value in comics you can't really
say that like King a lyric went on to
become a super hero but instead you kind
of have to really follow a lot of the
historical things that went on with
regards to the real world but what we
are introduced is King Alaric's nephew a
guy by the name of Eric now Eric as he's
shown here that's one of the cool things
about valiant is there's a lot of like
striking similarities with Thor from
Marvel Comics right but the cool thing
about this is that Eric is more grounded
Thor is kind of like an ideology he's
kind of like this metaphor for how
people view the world the Vikings nor
society how they view the world in terms
of like Icelandic people you know the
beauty of battle and dying in battle is
one of the best honors you can have and
going on to you know the afterlife
different things like that era kind of
follows this mindset in the sense that
it's really like you know battle is the
ultimate honor to die in battle is to
die bravely is to die in an honorable
way and so what rubberman did he does
right here well after that it seems like
Eric loves to fight he loves to engage
in combat and it's really cool to see
this happen because Ben did he's like
this guy's got balls this guy's tough I
mean he's going through just ripping
people to shreds you know fighting all
these enemies off and then again it just
kind of picks up later on that night in
this Vista goth camp now what we find
out here is that his father you know is
essentially mortally wounded but the
time will come when its father will
basically pass on which is exactly what
happens and what if father says the fall
of the Visigoths is at hand they're
going to come crashing down they're
going to come to an end what Eric needs
to do is spend time with his wife as
much as you can you know enjoy what
little life he has left this is the cool
thing about this because whenever it
comes to like societies that were
conflict at worship battle different
societies are depicted different ways
for example the Spartans from the time
they were born until the time they died
it was battle 100% of the time but we
always kind of have in the back of our
heads this notion that as people get
older they get a little wiser and they
say maybe being in conflict all the time
isn't the worst thing you know maybe if
you know you're going to die then enjoy
the things that you have around you
enjoy your life as best you can the
issue with this is that Eric doesn't
really partake in this mindset instead
he's basically still young he's brash he
loves the idea of conflict the other
half of this is that his wife had
basically been taken by the Romans now
for the most part she was being whisked
off to the Roman Empire but in the midst
of this conversation really in the midst
of his final moments with his father um
one of the guys for one of the men
cigars comes running in and says hey
look there's a transport ship on the
west now keep in mind here that this is
basically a primitive Society that's
really all this is you know despite how
it is a rubber Venditti has been talking
how relevant daddy has them
communicating there are very primitive
society and this will become prevalent
and we basically pick up with this next
phase will they're all basically take it
away and that's the crazy thing about
this what I mean here is that steel when
they initially come across you know
these invaders these Romans as they've
received them to be you know they kill a
couple of them but then when they remove
the mask they're just kind of like what
what what devilry is this what weapon is
this you know this is this is insane
this is you know this is something of
the demons because for them is simply
technology they don't understand I mean
this by an alien race is from beyond the
planet Earth their technology is far
more advanced and so in the eyes of the
Visigoths it's the devil's work it's
tantamount to when potatoes were first
brought over to Europe and people who
didn't know what potatoes were thought
they were created by the devil and so
it's just a crazy situation where it's
like we don't exactly understand
everything that's going on but it's cool
to see this dichotomy between like a
primitive society and in advance of
fighting in terms of how one views the
other now something else that then did
he does here and initially it seems like
he's coming out of left field but he
basically has a handful of the children
in this village basically replaced with
these vine replicants you know these
these blind children that are there to
essentially function as duplicates and
the actual children themselves are
basically whisked away now what the nd D
is doing is he's setting the stage for
something much bigger on and of course
it doesn't really take a genius to
realize that it's basically just the
idea of having vine replicants on earth
to carry out their whims carry out their
wishes and once
down the line but while you know Eric
and his guys try to fight back in the
end you know commander trill the one
that's leading this vines field mission
basically is able to make quick work of
them you know and just throw them on
this ship and whisk them away and so at
this point then did he transfers over it
will just kind of moves over to this
idea of how we look at Eric and these
various guys around him in relation to
this more advanced society not only that
you know we learned that it's not just
the Visigoths who have been taken away
as long as these soldiers move in with
the way there are other people here now
we will not find out exactly how far
this reach goes until the next little
while but what we also learned is that
there's something called Shana Hara the
armor of Shawn Hara now the way this
armor is detected this is the cool thing
about this it's depicted very much as
like a holy relic you know were you
where it's like the priesthood that
looks at it is something holy something
to be worshiped and that every once in a
while somebody will undertake the
attempt to Don the armor and if they
fail they'll basically die so it's kind
of like this more extreme version of
like the King Arthur's sword you know
whoever it is that can pick up Excalibur
will become the ruler of England is
really this cool notion of grabbing
these historical myths these historical
concepts doing them all into one huge
story and then just sort of giving it to
us at the same time again it's really
just the Venditti saying hey look this
is direction that things are going to go
in this is really how the Man O'War
armor essentially shows up here now the
other half of this is that for Eric and
his own people the idea is to basically
make your escape and one of the cool
things about this is then did me still
have them focus heavily on the Roman you
know for them it's like okay whatever's
going on here we'll get out of this and
then we'll go back and we'll kill those
Roman dogs what Ben did he's really
showing is that Eric end of himself is
very basic
he's a very simple minded person now it
doesn't mean that Ben did he's saying
he's stupid it's simply been did he's
saying this is how he functions this is
how a lot of people back then functioned
at the time when you're talking about a
relatively small part of the world
especially when you had barbarians who
didn't have massive navies and weren't
surfing the world it was a very small
place all they knew is what was around
them you know that's where those stories
of sailors you know drifting off into
the sunset yeah sure they go into the
sunset and they basically just travel
out of sight but if you didn't know
about the world if you don't didn't know
the world was round all you knew was
they just go into the sunset and
suddenly they're gone they just fell off
the face of the earth it's this whole
concept being applied to this and the
sin
that with Eric and his guys looking at
these these vines soldiers or I guess
these vine guards being made to work in
these gardens you know when when they
basically kick on sprinklers you know
and they have these sprinklers basically
watering this garden they look around
they're like wow I mean it's rain
without a sky what kind of magic is this
what kind of sorcery is this you know
and it's kind of funny to see that now
what we also get is then did he telling
us that this vine is very much a plant
based organism in the sense that one of
the guys who's basically being made to
work in this garden takes a bite of what
looks like an apple or a fruit of some
kind and of course when he struck down
by the Garver basically learned that
it's essentially its offspring that's it
was basically eating one of the children
but again it's kind of in diddy giving
us this general idea of how these vine
function of what these vine are but not
only that the the lengths they will go
to to make their point now something
else what I also want you to take note
of here is that we as the reader can see
what the vine there say we are vine you
obey us you do not disobey us we can see
that kind of thing for Eric and his guys
they don't have a clue what they're
saying all they hear is clicks and
chirps and it's really funny because
when you sit back and you look at this
it's like okay we know exactly what's
going on how do they not understand what
it is this being said it's this language
barrier and it creates a really weird
dichotomy because no one really
understands what's going on from the
perspective of Eric from the perspective
of goth key you know these Vista costs
that were whisked away from their
homeland thrown into a cell and over the
course of the next several however many
years today made the work in this camp
they don't know why they don't know why
they're there they don't know what the
endgame is here they don't know if
there's really just made to work until
they die they have no clue what the
whole basis is behind all this all they
know is that some alien race they can't
understand has seized control of them
now the other half of this is we
basically learned that the different
races are the different aspects of
humanity that have been taken aboard
this fine ship stretch across the world
and this is denne denne telling us that
when it came to the vine grabbing you
know these different societies of humans
they were grabbing them for their
ability to work they're basically going
around to these warrior territories you
know from Malaysia and all these
different places they were grabbing
individuals who were the most capable in
terms of their fighting prowess and
bringing them here and so it tells us a
few things what it does is it tells us
that one piece vine has probably been
watching the earth for quite some time
they've been traveling around they've
been looking at people saying hey what's
the best kind of person to harvest
you're an extremely strong person and
extremely capable person
not necessarily the smartest but
somebody that can do their job now this
is kind of interesting because it's very
Aristotelian it's very Aristotle like
for Vendetta to fill this in here what I
mean is that if you go back and look at
a lot of the old writings of Aristotle
he would make the argument that there
are some people who are just designed to
do certain jobs a person who is very
very strong who's very large but who has
like a mental deficiency who's you know
who Aristotle would deem as being not
very intelligent is a person that's
designed for work that's all they ever
need to do they just need to build
houses they just need to lay bricks you
know whatever it is they don't need to
be you know politicians because they
weren't designed for that whereas
somebody who may be very frail or
somebody who's extremely intelligent but
not the strongest would be a person best
suited for politics now that's a very
narrow perspective but it really seems
to be the idea to the vine we're looking
at it saying hey look if we're going to
have folks working on our farms we're
going to have folks tending to our
gardens they need to be strong we to
make them last as long as we can because
it's not like they grab the whole of
humanity you know however many people
were residing on earth entirely and
threw them all on there they just
grabbed a handful so in truth they have
to kind of make them last as long as
possible so with regards to Eric and his
guys basically orchestrating an escape
it's really been Diddy kind of thinning
the herd with stories like this when
it's like you know when it's a story
called XO Man O'War well it revolves
around a guy it's not like exilim ant of
war and there's like 50 different Man
O'War so at least not now anyway not at
this point in the story but with regards
to Erik when he and his group make their
escape it's really cool to see this
because it's again VIN did he saying
that when it comes to a warrior mindset
that there's a commonality among them
that they recognize a warrior when they
see once that you know Erik could sit
down with a guy from them from another
part of the world who knows battle and
say we've been forged in the fires of
combat you know we value freedom above
all else when tomorrow comes we'll live
or we'll die as free men it's a common
theme it's a common concept what is
their fighting for their own freedom
whether they're fighting for the freedom
of others the fact remains that the
mindset behind why they fight is all the
same and so ultimately once they get
into this armory you know as was
described by the man who gave you know
Erik this map they get into I realize
there's no brand armory there's not like
all these different guns all these huge
you know things instead it's just like
this giant ball now of course when Erik
gets up to it and Erik dawns you know
this armor of course the response to the
priest is he was a fool for doing it one
because the armor of shun Hara
would not pick a lowly human you know
not only that so many other people have
tried and if the vine couldn't wear it
well surely a human can try now of
course this is humorous but it's also
really cool to see that the armor does
pick EXO Manowar picks it picks Eric
there we go and he's officially able to
Don the armor and basically take on the
EXO Man O'War mantle now the cool thing
about this has been then did he kind of
give us this tour of what the armor is
capable of in the sense that it grants
him enhanced strength it grants him
regenerative capabilities you know it
seems to be resistant to a lot of the
weapons that are currently being used by
the by the vine also is very capable in
terms of its abilities and it really
turns Eric into like a one-man army now
we know this by way of the fact that of
course his hand that have previously
been cut off due to insubordination is
essentially restored but what we also
find out here at least what we also see
here is that the various guys were with
him are donned with the guns that the
other Vaughn were using before Eric had
killed them that while they're
essentially almost kind of thinned out
while they're are eliminated through one
one form or another Eric just takes it
to all of them takes it to all these
vines and just starts crushing all of
them of course he you know has some
measure of flight you're able to project
himself in a you know one particular
direction but in the end he's drawing
the attention of the vine in a way that
basically sees them traveling to earth
for full-on invasion and the reason for
this is because the actions of EXO
Manowar as he's here you know as he's
fighting these guys and he keeps
shouting Rome the suit basically
teleports him to modern-day Rome the
reason why I say that it's going to
initiator at least it seems like it's
going to initiate what amounts to a
full-on invasion is because of the fact
that when he shows up here on earth he
immediately draw the attention of police
we no one has any idea what's going on
it's just suddenly this guy just appears
in Rome donning this armor not only that
we end up having commander trill
speaking what they're admiral and saying
hey look the armor of Shauna Hara has
appeared on earth it's only going to be
a matter of time before the Earthlings
begin asking where is this armor come
from what's this armor capable of god
forbid they get their hands on Eric and
they begin the process of dissecting the
armor to make it make duplicates there's
any number of things that they can do
with that and so because of this the
only the only response really seems to
be an invasion of earth now with regards
to Eric himself as he's in Rome and of
course as the various military itself in
Rome trying to take him out because they
don't know what he is when he seizes one
of the pilots this is when he
learns the truth that when he was on the
ship and he was you know working on this
camp it wasn't like he was gone for 20
years you know because of how fast the
ship was traveling from one side of the
universe to the other and so on that he
basically realizes that sixteen hundred
years have passed that he's been gone
for almost two thousand years that
everything has changed the Visigoths are
gone the Roman Empire no longer exists
and this is why this story is so cool
this is one of the reasons why the story
works so well is because Eric is
basically a man thrown out of time for
what the story does it's taking a more
interesting approach of him just you
know being thrust into a time portal and
since 1,600 years in the future I mean
it maintains his whole element of being
a being a warrior it maintains his whole
element or is whole perception of what
it means to fight but now the reason why
he's fighting is basically gone if the
Roman Empire isn't fair well then
clearly his wife is probably dead and if
his wife is dead and there's no Roman
Empire for him to defeat then what
purpose does he have and that's why this
story takes on such a cool approach
because now with him basically just kind
of dealing with the world as a whole
trying to figure out his place in it now
at this point we actually switch to
Manhattan and we pick up with a guy
named Alexander and this is when we
start to learn that the vine are really
just going into the realm of a
full-scale invasion and what I mean here
is that Alexander is the sixteen hundred
years later result of these babies in
Visigoths being replaced with vine
replicants Alexander is essentially a
vine flat taking on human form
it's basically allowed the vine to
infiltrate a multitude of human society
now the reason why this was so cool the
reason why this works is because we've
seen a million stories right where you
know like some alien race just invades
the planet Earth it would have been so
easy to do that you know with alien
races invades or it's a neo they they
fight for you know eight seconds so they
fight for three hours they fight for
years in and in the end the alien races
successful at comprehending it would
have been easy to do that but I
personally find it a lot more intriguing
if an alien race is basically able to
subvert the governments of the world by
replacing various people with their own
replicants because then the question
becomes who's actually human and who is
not not only that it allows us a lien
race to basically rule from the shadows
to control from the shadows and so again
it really brings in this concept of
subterfuge of espionage you know it
makes the story a lot more interesting
that it would have been any other way if
it was just a guy you know who reappears
over 1,600 years he's being chased by an
alien race which decides to invade the
earth to make sure nobody else can get
ahold of the armor it makes his story a
lot more interesting but yeah I mean
when it comes to the character of éxito
man-of-war I mean it's really into the
first line the next one actually picks
up with : King and then Jack when it
comes to the character of EXO man-of-war
he really stands out is like valiums
premier character you know value it's
like number one guy he's dying Superman
he's valiant spider-man because in a lot
of ways he kind of elevated valiant to
the height of their popularity during
the early 90s and it was the first title
that valia came out with if I remember
correctly when they did their whole
relaunch
and so it makes a lot of sense to kind
of look at his character and say he's
really like the frontman you know he's
the guy that you used to get started in
to value comics but I also like his
character because I love the idea of a
guy being a man out of time you know how
do you take a person that lived in a
society to sixteen hundred years old and
is no longer in existence how do you
have that guy exist in the modern day
and how does he view the world a man
with a warrior's mentality living in a
society that does not have a warrior's
mentality how do you square that circle
Rob core but if you guys are new here to
commerce explain make sure you guys with
the sub button to become part of the Rob
port you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all at it please
[Music]
you